I know what you're thinking
who the hell is that handsome young baby
ah where did my face go what's the point
god I'm so angry today we're going to
play a video game about not moving it's
impossible I don't know that's why I'm
sitting down alright this is technically
the first video I record with a new
oculus it's pretty cool I like how it
feels
you have the headphones built-in and now
we're gonna play don't let go hopefully
you guys can see it so I played the
office check out the video now we're
gonna play desert do not play if you
have fear okay oh my god oh my god I'm
in the desert this is so cool what
happens in the desert alright so these
are the control wait I gotta got the
lens here it's all smudgy from my face
face part for an explanation and [ __ ]
see it is really cool now cuz the oculus
you move with your body
this wasn't a thing before so if I
wanted to suck someone's dig down let's
see if I can find both controllers Oh
like I'm squatting this is so weird
this is so [ __ ] weird hey okay
alright I'm not [ __ ] around let's go
I did it alright that's a scorpion okay
that's a bug we're watching Vicky pedia
scorpions where's the scorpion the [ __ ]
are you you son of a [ __ ] oh god it
really feels like my hands are you
[ __ ] you'd escape it
Oh what that is so weird
no don't touch my thumb oh god it's
gonna sting me oh please what are you
I'm so tempted to let go
welcome sponge Erica thank you I love
you Wow
still alive thank you sponsor eagle
you're my best friend be free Oh Jeff
nut oh my god
better not be sponsor bootjet that
[ __ ] sponsor eagle I mean I love you
thank you have a snack yeah that's right
yeah that's some [ __ ] yeah and my
favorite Eagle Maine I will pet you but
you know I can't let go that's the point
of the game sponsor eagle were you
looking for oh my god is there someone
behind me no it's there cowboy I hate
Catholics they're scaring me that's my
biggest phobia are you gonna eat that or
can I have a slice come on oh Jesus the
[ __ ] was that okay well I guess I'll see
you later
Oh my headset but I can't let go its ear
[ __ ] me hey buddy how you doing there
buddy this is so [ __ ] up hmm I want to
let go so bad
can I kiss oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
Oh it goes back in the screen that's so
cool that is so cool
Thank You Wikipedia for teaching me
again oh god they're so well there I
just realized there's some well and
something's gonna come out of the well
god damn it what hi at night now you've
gotten too far man what that [ __ ] is
that I mean that no it's oh no no no
don't beat me up man I don't want to be
disinfect dissing the date dissected
whatever what is he doing he said
somebody's gonna come down
take me home mom take me to home where I
belong what is why are you a vote okay
well I ain't afraid of [ __ ] fairies
this is just nice a very scenic nature
good ain't you gonna [ __ ] eat Jimmy
what are they taste me bro come on taste
me brother
come on taste me then is this all you've
got I am not entertained
I would thumbs this down if I could use
my hands begone [ __ ]
thanks for nothing saw you a photo today
oh yeah what happened Oh a bunch of
sparkles blew up who gives a [ __ ]
Oh God in their frame Oh God the best
goddamn player on the planet I did not
let go well that was so cool
god damn that was cool you can check out
the video where I play the first one I
think the oculus works the best when you
are static like when you're just sitting
down and you're not moving because if
you move in the game and you're not
moving in real life that is what really
creates motion sickness I get motion
sick really easily but this works fine
this works excellent I want to see more
stuff like this I think that would be
really cool let me know what's your
opinion about the oculus what do you
think is it a gimmick is gonna catch on
I don't know I'm excited for the future
this has been pewdiepie playing don't
let go thank you so much for watching
and as always stay awesome